denn bei einer befehlsausgabe oder
überhaupt bei seinem zusammentreffen
wurde die frage gestellt wer kennt das
paar das amerikanische wer hat damit
schon einmal geschossen und ich war
damals der einzige der der der source
der wattener lizum gekannt hat und die
auch eine einen einzigen schuss damit
abgefeuert hat und na und so habe gesagt
ja ich kennt und daraufhin gesagt okay
du gehst mit zwei mann hinunter nach
nickelsdorf und da unten sind zwei
russische panzer aufgefahren und wir
begegnen der bedrohung mit einem panzer
abwehr trug nach coach ein
und es müssen sich vorstellen jetzt
kommen sie auf einmal mit einem
geschulterten banzer abwehr kommen sie
mit zwei mann mit zwei kameraden dort
hinunter
die führen sie mit dem chip an entlang
der durch was noch nach dem tollhaus
entlang der straße und der der jeep
fahrrad der war heilfroh dass er wieder
umkehren konnte weil er all england
entfernung von 3 400 meter die zwei
bands gesehen hat und hat gesagt dass er
bringe ich daher ich bin schon wieder
fort und und jetzt sind wir dran
im straßenraum gelegen und mit
zusammengesetzten bahn zur abwehr und
kam nun hinüber geschaut was machten die
beiden panzern und die haben aber ihre
rohre landeinwärts gedreht und und sind
bei offener luke erfasst herr außen
brauchen auch hinter weise sind die
russischen soldaten dort gesessen und so
haben wir eigentlich die zwei stunden
die wir dort gelegen sind dennoch zwei
stunden war dann die ablöse komplett
hinüber geschaut auf die fahrbahn so was
machen die